[Música]
expectativa en reino unido por la
votación legislativa de este martes
sobre nuevas medidas restrictivas para
frenar la propagación de kobe 19 el
denominado plan b de inglaterra
propuesto por boris johnson podría
enfrentar la oposición de algunos de sus
colegas conservadores tenemos informes
de londres
luto en haití al menos 50 muertos dejó
una explosión tras el choque de un
camión cisterna de transporte de
combustible las autoridades intentan
esclarecer el hecho pero presumen que el
vehículo estaba siendo saqueado en medio
de una grave crisis de suministro de
combustible que ha disparado el tráfico
ilegal
crecen las tensiones entre eeuu y china
en su gira por la región indo pacífica
el secretario de estado de joe biden
llamó a beijing a detener acciones que
calificó de agresivas en respuesta china
acusó a su contraparte de fomentar las
divisiones e instigar a la confrontación
en la región
gracias por continuar con nosotros
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo en
france24 soy daniel hablando comenzamos
en reinounido la cámara de los comunes
vota este martes el denominado plan b de
inglaterra una estrategia con la que el
premio en el primer ministro boris
johnson busca hacerle frente a la masiva
propagación de la variante omicron de
kobe 19 el premier se enfrentaría al
desafío de sus propios colegas
conservadores quienes consideran las
medidas violatorias de las libertades de
los ciudadanos recibimos el reporte de
nuestra corresponsal en londres louis ha
pulido
la votación de esta noche del plan b en
el parlamento sea en medio de una crisis
de credibilidad del primer ministro por
la realización de al menos tres fiestas
de navidad en diciembre de 2020 cuando
el país estaba en medio de estrictas
restricciones que es un hecho que ha
negado el gobierno pero que ha tenido un
gran efecto político y en el público se
cree además que esta noche de boris
johnson vivirá su primera rebelión
dentro de su propio partido el
conservador se votará entonces este plan
b que incluye medidas de emergencia ante
la amenaza que la variante o micro en
representa para el reino unido
entonces se votará el uso obligatorio de
tapabocas en transporte público en
lugares cerrados pero no en pubs ni en
restaurantes es una medida polémica la
vacunación obligatoria para trabajadores
del sistema nacional público de salud
para abril de 2022 pruebas diarias de
personas que tengan la vacunación
completa que hayan tenido contacto
cercano con alguien positivo de kobe y
también algo qué causa polémica y furia
dentro del partido conservador es el
pasaporte de vacunas que empezará a
regir este miércoles para eventos
masivos sin embargo algunos
conservadores se cree que un grupo de 80
votará en contra de su gobierno al
considerar que este pasaporte de vacunas
restringe las libertades personales si
se cumplen estas proyecciones de esos 80
rebeldes entonces el gobierno estaría en
aprietos para aprobar el plan b entonces
debe confiar en los partidos de
oposición como el laborista la segunda
fuerza en este país que ha dicho que sí
que va a apoyar al gobierno en este plan
seguimos hablando de la pandemia en
europa porque el consejo científico
alerta en francia sobre la posibilidad
de una sexta ola de contagios de kobe 19
en invierno mientras la variante omicron
se propaga por europa crece el miedo a
una fuerte presión en los servicios
hospitalarios entretanto el gobierno de
manuel macro no estaría contemplando
endurecer los controles de viajeros
provenientes del reino unido en donde
fue reportada la primera muerte por este
nuevo linaje detalles a continuación
podría propagarse muy rápidamente según
el último aviso del consejo científico
la variante omicron circula en europa de
manera más fuerte a lo previsto y
amenaza con convertirse en la dominante
en francia up in the best company and
good luck simon
johnson con la prioridad debería
propagarse un poco más lentamente en
francia que en reino unido porque
estamos algo más vacunados con la
tercera dosis pero como se propaga más
fácilmente que la variante delta es muy
probable que en las próximas semanas la
sobrepase y provoque un rebrote
epidémico
down delta y jugo que colbún y piti
míchel una dinámica que podría
incrementar la presión en los hospitales
según el sitio web como beat tracker las
admisiones en cuidados intensivos ya han
aumentado un 27% en relación a la semana
anterior estudio todos los días hay
personas que llegan a cuidados
intensivos cada día el número de
personas que llegan en esta situación es
superior al día anterior ellos guapa
como hace la ssa jose a dec la billion
no veo como nos las vamos a arreglar con
la llegada de un micrón ante esta
amenaza el consejo científico pide
evitar las grandes reuniones por las
fiestas de navidad que podrían acelerar
los contagios
y eeuu superó el lunes la marca de los
50 millones de contagios por kobe de 19
de acuerdo con la universidad johns
hopkins
798 mil personas han muerto por
coronavirus en ese país la cifra se
alcanza cuando ya circula la variante
omicron más en el siguiente informe de
luís mentes
el 14 de diciembre de 2020 sandra
lindsay una enfermera de la ciudad de
nueva york fue la primera persona en
recibir una dosis de la vacuna contra el
cob y 19 un año después lejos de haber
superado la crisis está se mantiene con
un número de contagios en aumento y que
ya supera los 50 millones ello llevó al
estado de nueva york a imponer nuevas
medidas
people
las personas que atienden en casa es una
situación pero cuando presionan a un
sistema de salud agotado y hablo por
cada persona que trabaja allí incluyendo
a los altos ejecutivos por casi dos años
cualquier cosa que podamos hacer para
ayudar a aliviar esa olla de presión es
una de mis prioridades
es formar genes parís en otros estados
los contagios y hospitalizaciones
mantienen el sistema de salud colapsado
y el número de pacientes por la
enfermedad empieza a generar tensiones
entre los trabajadores de la salud hoy
fue bastante difícil porque es mi
tercero esta semana lo siento en eeuu el
brote de ccoo y 19 ha causado la muerte
de 798 mil personas más que en ningún
otro país del mundo y con un promedio de
30.000 muertes diarias en el último mes
el gobierno de haití declaró tres días
de luto nacional después de que medio
centenar de personas murieran en el
norte del país tras la explosión de un
camión cisterna que transportaba
combustible la alcaldía de cabo haitiano
la segunda ciudad más grande de la isla
detalló que el accidente se produjo
cuando unas 100 personas trataban de
saquear el vehículo el país experimenta
problemas de abastecimiento de
combustible desde octubre pasado lo que
ha llevado a un aumento de su tráfico
ilegal el gobierno también elevó
drásticamente los precios de los
derivados de los combustibles la semana
pasada
se decretarán tres días de luto nacional
en todo el país en memoria de las
víctimas de esta tragedia que ha sumido
en el luto a toda la nación haitiana los
hospitales de campaña se desplegarán
rápidamente en cabo haitiano para
proporcionar la atención necesaria a las
víctimas de esta terrible explosión
y en colombia murieron al menos tres
personas como consecuencia de la
explosión de dos artefactos cerca del
aeropuerto internacional camilo daza de
la ciudad de cúcuta el presidente iván
duque calificó el hecho de ataque
terrorista mientras que las autoridades
aeronáuticas suspendieron las
operaciones en el terminal aéreo en
junio pasado la explosión de un
automóvil en instalaciones militares
dejó 36 heridos en esta convulsa ciudad
fronteriza con venezuela
criminales ingresaron al aeropuerto
camilo daza
donde detonó un artefacto explosivo
entre la plataforma y la maikel causante
de eso se identifican unos restos
humanos minutos más tardes nuestros
especialistas para hacer el
reconocimiento de la zona identifica una
maleta al acercarse con todas las
medidas de seguridad detonó nuestros 2
explosivista ofrendaron la vida por la
seguridad en este momento seguimos
recolectando todos los elementos
materiales de prueba para identificar
cómo fue el modo como ingresaron y la
autoría del grupo criminal y terrorista
hay nuevas fricciones entre la casa
blanca y beijing el secretario del
estado de eeuu anthony blinken está de
gira por la región indo pacífica para
profundizar sus alianzas durante su
visita a indonesia el funcionario
advirtió que eeuu sus aliados y algunos
reclamantes del mar de china meridional
rechazarían cualquier acción ilegal por
parte del gobierno de xi jinping que
reclama casi todo este territorio como
suyo china por su parte considera la
postura de washington como una
interferencia que podría amenazar la
estabilidad regional
estamos decididos a garantizar la
libertad de navegación en el mar de
china meridional donde las acciones
agresivas de beijing amenazan el
movimiento de más de 3 billones de
dólares en comercio cada año
los métodos de eeuu para enfrentar a la
división e instigar la confrontación son
impopulares en todo el mundo y esto
definitivamente no funcionará en la
región de asia y el pacífico
con
ustedes gracias por su sintonía tenemos
más en france 24 y en france 24 punto
com
[Música]